en el vídeo pasado aprendimos un poco
acerca de la fotosíntesis y sabemos que
en términos muy generales la
fotosíntesis es un proceso en el que
empezamos con fotones dióxido de carbono
y agua y usamos la energía de esos
botones para fijar el carbono del
dióxido de carbono y ahora toda esta
idea de la fijación del carbono se trata
de tomar al carbono en su forma gaseosa
como por ejemplo en el dióxido de
carbono y fijarlo en alguna estructura
sólida y esta estructura sólida en la
que estamos fijando al carbono es un
carbohidrato el principal producto final
de la fotosíntesis es esta cadena de 3
carbonos este glitter aldehído 3 fosfato
pero luego podemos usar esto para
construir glucosa o cualquier otro
carbohidrato
que una vez que ya dijimos todo esto
ahora vamos a intentar observar a fondo
qué es lo que realmente está pasando en
estas fases de la fotosíntesis recuerda
dijimos que había dos fases en la
fotosíntesis la fase que depende de la
luz y la otra fase que es independiente
de la luz a mí no me gusta usar el
nombre de fase oscura porque esta fase
puede ocurrir incluso cuando tenemos luz
solar
esta fase incluso está sucediendo al
mismo tiempo que la fase luminosa la
única diferencia es que esta fase no
necesita que haya luz solar pero bueno
primero nos vamos a enfocar en la fase
luminosa que es la fase que se utiliza a
los fotones de la luz solar o bueno los
fotones de las lámparas que se pueden
utilizar en invernaderos
y es que esta fase utiliza los botones
junto con el agua para producir
moléculas de atp y para reducir
moléculas de bp más
en a dp h ok porque recuerda que
reducción es obtener electrones o átomos
de hidrógeno y eso es exactamente lo
mismo porque cuando obtienes un átomo de
hidrógeno con todo y su electrón como el
hidrógeno no es muy electro negativo la
molécula puede abrazar mucho a ese nuevo
electrón así es que aquí está haciendo
ambas cosas ganando un hidrógeno y un
electrón pero ahora queremos estudiarlo
un poquito más a fondo así es que vamos
a dibujar por aquí la célula de una
planta lo que ahí vamos a dibujar una
célula vegetal y las células vegetales
de hecho tienen una pared celular
entonces las podemos dibujar de una
forma rígida cada uno de estos
cuadriláteros es una célula vegetal
distinta y luego en cada una de estas
células vegetales
hay unos organelos que se llaman
cloroplastos y recuerda los organelos
son como los órganos pero de las células
y son subunidades de la célula que
pueden tener su propia membrana
por supuesto estas células vegetales
tienen su núcleo y su adn y todas las
demás cosas que tienen todas las células
pero no los vamos a dibujar ok
simplemente vamos a dibujar a los
cloroplastos y bueno hay muchas células
que pueden hacer fotosíntesis pero en
este vídeo nos vamos a enfocar en las
células vegetales porque generalmente
asociamos a la fotosíntesis con las
plantas y cada célula vegetal tiene
entre 10 y 50 cloroplastos aunque ya
estamos dibujando aquí los cloroplastos
y los estoy dibujando a propósito en
verde porque los cloroplastos contienen
clorofila y la clorofila hace que se
vean verdes para nuestros ojos y ahora
recuerda que cuando algo se ve verde es
porque está reflejando la luz verde y
absorbiendo las longitudes de onda de
todos los demás colores pero bueno de
esto hablamos con mucho detalle en otros
vídeos por el momento tenemos entre 10 y
50 de estos cloroplastos en cada célula
vegetal y lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es hacer un acercamiento a uno de
estos cloroplastos ahora vamos a dejar
un poco más claro esto que tenemos aquí
este cuadrilátero esto de aquí es una
célula vegetal célula vegetal y estos
organelos verdes de aquí se llaman
cloroplastos estos son los organelos
cloroplastos cloroplastos y aquí estamos
haciendo un acercamiento a un
cloroplasto aquí tenemos ese cloroplasto
que por cierto tiene su propia membrana
y se ve más o menos así y luego adentro
del cloroplasto tenemos un líquido y
este líquido se llama estroma estroma y
además adentro del cloroplasto tenemos
unos sacos aplanados que son como unas
membranas dobladas que estamos dibujando
por aquí estos sacos aplanados
y de hecho hasta los podríamos ver como
unos tanques pero vamos a dibujar unos
cuantos más por acá
y cada uno de estos tanques aplanados se
llama anti la coidh es esto de aquí es
un tila coi de tila koi de lost y la
coidh es tienen su propia membrana y esa
membrana es especialmente importante y
por lo tanto vamos a hacer un
acercamiento pero en unos cuantos
minutos por el momento estamos
resaltando esa membrana pero ahora el
espacio adentro del tila coi de el
fluido que está adentro del tila coi de
que estoy coloreando de amarillo este se
llama lumen y la cordal
y ya para terminar de ver toda la
terminología un montón de ti la coidh es
apilados de esta forma se llama grana
aunque hay una pila de ti la coidh es se
llama grana
y los cloroplastos son organelos y una
cosa que piensan los biólogos
evolucionistas es que los organelos al
principio hace mucho tiempo empezaron
siendo organismos independientes que
eventualmente empezaron a hacer equipo
con otros organismos y empezaron a vivir
adentro de las células y por eso es que
organelos como el cloroplasto tienen su
propio adn la mitocondria es otro
organelos que tienen su propio adn y que
muchas personas piensan que
originalmente era un organismo
independiente y que después hizo un
equipo con otros organismos y les dijo
oye qué te parece si yo te doy energía y
tú a cambio me das no sé comida y otras
cosas y entonces estos organismos
empezaron a evolucionar juntos y
terminaron formando un solo organismo
regresando al cloroplasto los
cloroplastos incluso tienen sus propios
ribosomas así es que me parece súper
interesante darnos cuenta que los
cloroplastos o bueno los ancestros de
los cloroplastos pudieron haber sido
organismos independientes pero bueno
dejemos todas estas especulaciones y
ahora sí vamos a hacer otro acercamiento
a la membrana de los de la coidh es así
es que lo que vamos a hacer es poner por
aquí una cajita y vamos a poner por acá
esa cajita pero con muchísimo
acercamiento hicimos un acercamiento a
la membrana del tila coi de lo que hay
esta es la membrana del tila coi de que
de hecho es una bicapa fosfolípidos que
tiene su parte hidrofílica y sus colas
hidrofóbicas y podría dibujar toda la
membrana de esta forma
pero no lo vamos a hacer porque lo
importante es simplemente que sepamos
que esta es una membrana por aquí lo que
tenemos es este líquido que llena a todo
el cloroplasto que es el estroma
stroman pero de este lado estamos
adentro del til acoide y adentro del
tila koide tenemos el lumen y la coidh
al aunque hay por aquí lo voy a dibujar
de rosa
ahora aquí tenemos el lumen lumen y
ahora en esta membrana lo que voy a
hacer a continuación te recordará
muchísimo a la mitocondria ya la cadena
de transporte de electrones porque bueno
en realidad si vamos a ver una cadena de
transporte de electrones muchas personas
no la consideran la cadena de transporte
de electrones pero es exactamente la
misma idea
bueno la misma idea general en esta
membrana tenemos todas estas proteínas y
estos complejos de proteínas y moléculas
a lo largo de toda la membrana y aquí
vamos a dibujar algunos de estos
complejos vamos a dibujar por aquí por
ejemplo el foto sistema 2 y tal vez por
acá tenemos el foto sistema 1 y ahora
estos en realidad son extremadamente
complicados y le vamos a echar un
vistazo rápido al foto sistema 2 por
aquí tenemos el foto sistema 2 como
podemos observar por aquí real
es un sistema muy complejo tenemos estos
cilindros por aquí estas proteínas estas
cosas verdes de aquí son moléculas de
clorofila y hay un bonche de cosas por
aquí y todas están revueltas e
interconectadas mutuamente así es que me
parece que un complejo es la mejor forma
de describir a esto porque hay porque
son un montón de moléculas un montón de
proteínas y todo tipo de cosas
interconectadas para realizar una
función muy específica que vamos a
describir en unos cuantos segundos
regresando nos a la célula vegetal así
es que acabamos de ver más o menos cómo
se ve el complejo fotosistema 2 por aquí
este complejo es el foto sistema 1 y
bueno aquí en medio hay muchos otros
complejos por ejemplo el complejo del
citocromo b6 efe la verdad no me pienso
meter a ver todos los detalles de los
complejos que hay aquí en medio porque
lo más importante es entender qué es lo
que está pasando así es que por aquí
tenemos otros complejos proteicos
a lo largo de toda la membrana y vamos a
ver primero la idea general y después
vamos a ver los detalles pero esta es la
idea general de qué es lo que sucede en
las reacciones de la fase luminosa en la
fase dependiente de la luz si es que
estamos en la fase de pendiente de la
luz reacciones dependientes de la luz la
fase luminosa la idea general es que
tenemos muchos fotones fotones que han
viajado 93 millones de millas para
llegar hasta aquí así es que tenemos
estos fotones que viajan un montón de
tiempo y llegan y excitan a los
electrones de una molécula de clorofila
lo que hay de hecho de la molécula de
clorofila
pero bueno no me quiero meter en tantos
detalles así es que excitan a los
electrones de la molécula de clorofila y
entonces estos entran en un estado de
energía más alto bueno tal vez no lo
debí de haber dibujado así pero el punto
es que estos electrones
a un estado de energía alto y después
conforme van pasando de molécula en
molecular su nivel de energía va bajando
pero conforme va bajando su nivel de
energía
hay algunos protones de hidrógeno sin
sus electrones ok tenemos por aquí a
muchos protones de hidrógeno y conforme
el electrón va bajando de nivel de
energía estos protones de hidrógeno son
bombeados hacia el lumen ok son
transportados hacia el lumen y esto tal
vez te recuerde a la cadena de
transporte de electrones porque en esa
cadena
de la misma forma teníamos electrones
que pasaban de un potencial alto de un
nivel de energía alto a un nivel de
energía más bajo y conforme esos
electrones iban bajando su nivel de
energía esa energía se usaba para
transportar protones de hidrógeno a
través de una membrana en ese caso era
en la mitocondria pero
y es en un tila koide pero en ambos
casos estamos creando un gradiente ok
porque aquí llegan los fotones con mucha
energía y con esta energía los
electrones de la clorofila llegan a un
estado de energía más alto y luego va
bajando su nivel de energía conforme se
van moviendo a través de las moléculas
hasta que llegan al foto sistema 1 donde
nuevamente sube su nivel de energía
porque llega y les pega otro fotón bueno
todo esto que acabo de decir es algo muy
simplificado pero es una buena forma de
pensar en esto lo que hay aquí los
electrones otra vez tienen un alto nivel
de energía y conforme se mueven en las
moléculas va bajando su nivel de energía
y toda esa energía se está utilizando
para que pasen protones de hidrógeno a
través de la membrana ok esa energía se
está usando para bombear protones de
hidrógeno hacia el lumen así es que
eventualmente aquí vamos a tener una
enorme concentración de protones de
hidrógeno
lumen de la misma forma como en la
cadena de transporte de electrones de la
mitocondria aquí se va a utilizar esta
enorme concentración de protones de
hidrógeno para poder utilizar al
complejo atp sin tasa es posible que te
acuerdes de cómo se ve el complejo atp
si interesa pero lo estamos dibujando
por aquí y se ve más o menos así por
aquí en el lumen tenemos una gran
concentración de protones de hidrógeno
por lo cual estos protones de hidrógeno
se quieren regresar a la estroma y para
hacer eso tienen que pasar por el
complejo atp sin tasa si es que estos
protones de hidrógeno que tenemos
muchísimos por aquí estos protones de
hidrógeno van a encontrar su camino de
regreso a la estroma pasando a través
del complejo atp sin tasa y conforme
estos protones de hidrógeno van pasando
por aquí esto funciona tal cual como si
le estuvieran dando energía a esta
máquina de aquí y lo voy a ver con más
detalle cuando
la respiración celular pero por el
momento conforme estos protones de
hidrógeno pasan por aquí provocan que
esta parte del complejo atp sintasa
y este giro provoca que una molécula de
adp y un fosfato se enlacen formando un
atp aunque una molécula de a de p
y un grupo fosfato se unen para formar
una molécula de atp así es que este fue
un repaso muy general y voy a verlo con
más detalle próximamente pero este
proceso que acabamos de describir
se llama photo fosforilación photo
fosforilación y ahora porque se llama
photo fosforilación bueno pues la parte
de foto proviene del hecho de que
estamos utilizando fotones lo que hay de
que estamos utilizando la luz solar
estamos usando estos fotones para
excitar a los electrones de la clorofila
y luego conforme esos electrones
excitados que ahora tienen un alto nivel
de energía conforme esos electrones
pasan de una molécula a otra va bajando
su nivel de energía pero esa energía se
está usando para transportar a protones
de hidrógeno a través de la membrana
hacia el lumen y después los protones de
hidrógeno pues quieren regresar al
estroma
ok porque aquí en el lumen hay una alta
concentración de protones de hidrógeno
así es que estos protones quieren
atravesar la membrana a eso se le llama
hacer químicos mochis
entonces estos protones para regresar a
la estroma van a pasar por este complejo
atp sintasa ok se me olvidó ponerle
nombre por aquí pero este es el complejo
atp sin tasa de la atp sin tasa utiliza
el hecho de que los hidrógenos estén
pasando a través de ella para juntar
moléculas de adp y fosfato produciendo
atp ahora
al principio cuando estábamos hablando
acerca de la fase luminosa y la fase
oscura vimos que la fase luminosa tiene
algunos productos tiene el atp y el n
dp h porque durante la fase luminosa el
m
bp fue reducido ganó un hidrógeno y su
electrón y eso qué tiene que ver con lo
que estábamos viendo bueno pues si
estamos hablando de la foto
fosforilación a cíclica también conocida
como la fase luminosa a cíclica tenemos
que este electrón que fue pasando de
molécula en molécula al final se queda
en una molécula de n adepe más así es
que el aceptar final de electrones es n
además y una vez que éste acepta a ese
electrón y a uno de estos protones de
hidrógeno se transforma en n a dp h
otra cosa que dije por aquí es que
moléculas de agua se oxidan y obtenemos
oxígeno molecular pero eso en qué parte
sucede bueno pues por acá en el foto
sistema 2 en algún momento dijimos que
teníamos una molécula de clorofila y en
esa molécula hay un electrón que se
excita y llega a un nivel más alto de
energía y después va pasando de molécula
en molécula bajando su nivel de energía
pero aquí nos puede surgir la pregunta
de que podemos utilizar para sustituir a
ese electrón y resulta que utilizamos a
los electrones de las moléculas de agua
así es que tal cual por aquí tenemos
moléculas de agua que llegan y donan a
sus hidrógenos ya sus electrones así es
que nos podemos imaginar que estas
moléculas de agua donan dos protones de
hidrógeno y dos electrones para
sustituir a ese electrón que ahora tiene
un nivel de energía muy alto
qué se pasa de molécula en molécula
hasta llegar al photo sistema 1 y
finalmente quedarse en alguna molécula
así es que literalmente le estamos
quitando sus electrones al agua y cuando
le quitamos sus hidrógenos y sus
electrones al oxígeno nos queda
simplemente oxígeno molecular ahora la
razón por la que estoy haciendo tanto
énfasis y viendo esto con tanto detalle
es porque aquí está sucediendo algo muy
profundo bueno por lo menos a nivel
químico esto es algo muy profundo lo que
estamos haciendo aquí es oxidando al
agua oxidando agua y ahora el único
lugar en el reino biológico en el que
podemos encontrar un agente oxidante lo
suficientemente fuerte como para oxidar
el agua que por cierto si estás oxidando
agua básicamente lo que estás haciendo
es oxidar al oxígeno porque en realidad
le estás quitando estos electrones
al oxígeno del agua así es que estamos
oxidando al oxígeno y el único lugar
donde conocemos a un agente oxidante tan
fuerte como para quitarle electrones al
oxígeno es justo el fotosistema 2
así es que esto de aquí realmente es
algo profundo generalmente los
electrones están supercontentos en las
moléculas de agua están felices de girar
alrededor del oxígeno porque el oxígeno
es un átomo muy electro negativo que por
cierto es la razón por la que decimos
que una cosa se oxida porque
generalmente el oxígeno es un excelente
agente oxidante es buenísimo oxidando a
otros átomos pero aquí hemos encontrado
algo que es suficientemente fuerte como
para oxidar al oxígeno algo
suficientemente fuerte como para
quitarle sus electrones al oxígeno y
dárselo a la molécula de clorofila y
entonces un electrón es excitado por los
fotones y llega a un nivel de energía
más alto
y luego va bajando cada vez más del
nivel de energía hasta que llegue al
photo sistema 1 donde vuelve a ser
excitado a un nivel de energía más
grande gracias a los fotones y luego
otra vez vuelve a bajar cada vez más y
cada vez más de nivel de energía y
finalmente termina en una molécula de n
dp h y todo este tiempo que el electrón
estuvo pasando de un nivel de energía
más alto a un nivel de energía más bajo
esa energía se estuvo usando para
bombear protones de hidrógeno del
estroma al lumen y después se utiliza
ese gradiente para formar las moléculas
de atp en el próximo vídeo vamos a ver
un poco más del contexto acerca de qué
significa todo esto en términos de
niveles de energía de los electrones
pero esto es básicamente lo que está
sucediendo en la fase luminosa con los
fotones algunos electrones son excitados
y esos eventualmente terminan en una
molécula ndp h y conforme un electrón
pasa
ese estado excitado yendo cada vez a un
nivel más bajo de energía se bombean
protones de hidrógeno a través del
gradiente y luego ese gradiente se
utiliza para hacer que la atp sintasa
produzca moléculas de atp pero ese
electrón que eventualmente terminó en
esta molécula de bp
ese electrón tiene que ser reemplazado y
el reemplazo de ese electrón lo obtienen
quitándoselo a una molécula de agua así
es que a una molécula de agua le quitan
los dos protones de hidrógeno y le
quitan sus electrones y nos queda
simplemente oxígeno molecular y solo
para poder apreciar lo complejo de todo
este asunto regresamos a esto que te
había enseñado hace unos minutos que es
una pintura del foto sistema 2 no es que
el foto sistema 2 tenga estos cilindros
tal cual pero cada uno de estos
cilindros representa una proteína
llegó por aquí estas cosas verdes que
parecen como unos andamios todas estas
cosas verdes son moléculas de clorofila
y lo que sucede es que llegan los
fotones y le pegan a la clorofila aunque
bueno no necesariamente tienen que
pegarle a la clorofila ah también le
pueden pegar a algunas moléculas que se
llaman moléculas antena y las moléculas
de antena pueden ser otros tipos de
clorofila u otros tipos de moléculas
pero el punto es que un fotón o bueno
varios fotones llegan y excitan a varios
electrones por aquí que no
necesariamente tiene que ser en la
clorofila
puede ser en estos otros tipos de
clorofila o en unos pigmentos antena que
lo que hacen es absorber a los fotones y
luego sus electrones se exciten e
incluso lo podemos ver como una
vibración aunque cuando estamos hablando
a un nivel cuántico las vibraciones
realmente no tienen mucho sentido pero
es una muy buena analogía
que estos más o menos vibran hasta
llegar a la clorofila
y a eso se le llama energía de
resonancia energía de resonancia así es
que estos vibran y vibran hasta llegar a
la clorofila
y aquí el electrón se excita y bueno el
principal aceptar de electrones es este
de aquí que se llama fe oficina y muchas
personas le dicen simplemente feo y a
partir de aquí el electrón se va pasando
de una molécula a otra vamos a ver eso
un poquito más a detalle en el próximo
vídeo pero por ahora observemos lo
complejo que es todo esto y lo
fascinante que es que esto sirva para
excitar electrones cuya energía
permitirá que se bombeen protones de
hidrógeno a través de la membrana y por
aquí tenemos otro punto de interés este
es el lugar de oxidación del agua y es
un lugar muy interesante porque como ya
dijimos no es nada sencillo oxidar al
oxígeno
y es que tenemos aquí al súper
interesante lugar donde se puede oxidar
al oxígeno nuclear y sucede aquí en este
lugar del foto sistema 2 y tenemos todo
este mecanismo tan complicado porque
repito no es cualquier cosa poder
quitarles sus hidrógenos y sus
electrones a una molécula de agua bueno
aquí vamos a terminar este vídeo y en el
próximo vídeo vamos a ver un poco más
acerca de los estados de energía de los
electrones y también vamos a rellenar
algunos huecos que dejamos por ahí
acerca de cuáles son estas otras
moléculas que actúan como aceptar es de
hidrógeno que también los podemos ver
como aceptar es de electrones